what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
morning coffee thoughts where I give my
thoughts over morning coffee um today
I'm actually eating steak not
coffee but I wanted to talk about this
new thing that I started on Twitter so
if you guys follow my Twitter which is @
pearly things you'll see I've started a
series where I
am rating if women's outfits are
appropriate if you're a wife and a
mother
now why do I say appropriate for a wife
and a mother isn't it just
appropriate well my answer to that is
yes but I would say under the age of 25
you have you can claim
naivity now what does that mean
Pearl men and women both do stupid
when they're young uh you know they
they're more Reckless they're doing
whatever they're raised by the culture
to be a certain way but over the age of
25 um or especially when you have
children as a woman you're meant to
dress and move a little bit
differently now I want to start by
saying I am not without sin this is not
saying that I have never worn things
that are
inappropriate um I'm 6 foot and I grew
up playing volleyball and in volleyball
really you're wearing Spandex from the
age of 12 in front of hundreds of people
so you sort of grow up not really
honestly thinking much of short stuff
because
I mean that's what you grow up doing I
was an
athlete um and I actually came to the
realization that a lot of the stuff I
was wearing was way too short and it
actually frustrated me a lot because I
just could not find clothes that didn't
look like a grandma and were long enough
on me but that's that's for a different
day um and I had this realization I
started looking at the influencers um it
that kind of label them themselves as
more like tra or traditional and I
realized that a lot of them sort of
dressed like hookers a lot of
them and what I wanted to point out is
not attacking them personally but just
something we can learn about the outfits
you pick and the way you choose to
represent yourself in public and
online so um I really just felt like it
was time to start a movement or we say
ladies um especially when you are a wife
and a mother because that as a role it
is time to put the boobs away it's time
to put the butt away it's time to put
the mid drift away it's time to cover up
and put it all away and there was a time
when this was normal um I go back and I
look at pictures from the 1900s even the
1940s and 50s and that's still after the
first sexual revolution in the 20s women
were dressed a lot more
modestly now the the problem with women
is we tend to go with what's cool trendy
and in the culture um and the issue with
that is when women do do what is cool
trendy and in the culture the trends
that are trendy now were very
provocative and the entire media and
marketing is trying to sell clothes and
dresses towards women that are immodest
and yeah I just thought we should really
have a conversation as women and I
really wanted to know especially women's
thoughts in the comments what do
traditional women
wear what should be deemed appropriate
and what should be deemed inappropriate
so I had a couple things that I I wanted
to start with that were
inappropriate um I think we should start
and I'm not saying we can't go further
guys I know we can but I think as a
start um because we are in
2023 let's start by putting the upper
thigh away the mid drift
away and the upper thigh the mid drift
away the boobs away the butt away um so
no low cleavage no butt
out um I think at some point we can have
a conversation about yoga pants but
that's a different day um and I think
that's a start ladies um because at some
point becoming a wife and a mother is a
role and when
you are adapting and becoming that role
you know you're not supposed to dress
like a teenager now the push back I get
is from these mothers that are older
than me and claim they look better than
me and some of them do okay some of them
are hot um but it's not a good look when
you're 45 years old and you're
cosplaying as a
22-year-old I'm sorry younger women
dress differently than older women and
they are meant to that is a different
role you are meant to be valued for
different things when you are older
because looks fade for
everybody and if we can't have an honest
conversation about what's modest and
what's immodest you know I I'm just
trying to start the
conversation um so this these mothers
and wives will start tweeting at me
their selfies which again is just really
weird it's really weird like go and you
know it's one thing to wear something
immodest for your husband that's kind of
the push back well I look like this and
I dress like this for my husband but my
question is why are there pictures of
you
online why are there pictures of you
online for the world to see if it's for
your husband and I started to think
about how people sort of look at the man
a little bit funny when his girl is
dressed like a hooker I'll give you guys
an example I went to a business dinner a
couple of months ago and this girl came
with um one of the business guys guys
and this woman was dressed like a
complete hooker she was dressed like it
was it was ridiculous her boobs were I'm
like I thought we were talking about
business all I can see is this chick's
boobs like you know what I
mean um and it makes you look at the guy
funny because you think why aren't you
protecting your chick from the world who
is obviously going to
look you know you know what I mean
um
and it's an honest conversation about
what is appropriate and as a man do you
have a responsibility to look out for
your woman and make sure that she
dresses modestly now I know women in
2023 say men can't tell me anything but
I really do think that's partially the
responsibility of the man and on top of
that you know I could say the same thing
for men in sweatsuit and sneakers you
know I had had a co-host um that you
know that that who shall not be named
who decided to make a video calling me a
colonizer um who when we first started
the show together I sort of told him to
you know up the dress because he showed
up in a tracksuit and you know again
over a certain age it's time to dress
like an adult I'm not a style expert I'm
certainly not a fashion expert um but I
want to have the conversation what's
appropriate and what's inappropriate and
do the men have some
responsibility in how their women dress
let me know in the comments like the
video on your way out subscribe I'll
talk to you later